[Music]
Nicki Minaj calls out Travis Scott over
album sales she believes were boosted by
his girlfriend Kylie Jenner naka wage
walk him a piece like Khan
it seems like Nicki is lashing out at
Travis after his astral world album
surpassed her Queen album on the
Billboard 200 charts to veto line every
chart it's this post that has Nicki on
edge Kylie supporting her man's music
and revealing their little family is
hitting the road together
Nicki took to social media to air out
her frustrations writing in a series of
tweets quote I put my blood sweat and
tears in writing a dope album only for
Travis Scott to have Kylie Jenner post a
tour pass telling people to come see her
and stormy lol I'm actually laughing
whoever cast them into my concern the 35
year old rapper continued her rant and
claims she actually deserves the top
spot quote I spoke to him he knows he
doesn't have the number one album this
week I love my fans for the number one
album in America but Nicki says her
tweets were lost in translation
adding people are calling me thinking
I'm huffing and puffing oMG y'all this
is sarcasm / dry humor I mean it's
pretty out here
okay we'll see how it all pans out in
person at the 2018 MTV Video Music
Awards
[Music]
[Applause]